I've got some new tour dates to announce
uh excited to say we will be going to
the
Australia and that is going to be
Ackland New
Zealand and that's February 23rd Gold
Coast in the Australia on February 29
Brisbane in the Australia March 2nd
Melbourne on March 5th and Sydney in
March 8th both of those in the a
Australia pre-sale starts Thursday
December 14th at 10:00 a.m. local time
over there with code Rat King General on
sale begins Friday December 15 at 10:
a.m. local time we also have tickets
remaining for Charlottesville VA Raleigh
North Carolina Columbia South Carolina
State College PA Syracuse n y and
Amherst and we will also be looking to
add some shows over there in uh um and
you know where the
Australia um all tickets are available
at theo.
comom also if the tickets get
overpriced just wait don't go don't
waste your money on these uh secondary
sites we will um we'll add a date or
we'll come back and uh just just
thankful grateful to get to uh bring the
show and and have people see it man I
can't even believe it and um thank you
guys for being a part of this journey
with me praise God baby gang today's
guest is a an artist uh she's a tattoo
artist she is a um musician and she's
a uniquity a unique person in the world
uh she's a Christian and she's just had
quite a journey in life as we all have
uh we're grateful to sit down with her
today um today's guest is is my friend
Miss cat
[Music]
Von I'll sit and tell you my
stories
sh
me and I will find a song I will sing
[Applause]
it
go to the grocery
store those should to go you want to
pull the mic up are you okay with that
yeah whatever that's okay you're going
to the grocery store in those no I don't
go to the grocery store I yeah I can't
even I mean maybe like on Neptune or
something I feel like I don't know how I
wonder if they would even if I were at
the grocer I don't know if I would let
you in I think it almost looks like
you're
shopping uh we don't have to wear
glasses by the way I no we can take them
off I just I know that you yeah you
walked in with these and I was like wow
yeah I feel like that was virtual
reality before they had kind of virtual
reality I guess well yeah cuz the like
glasses like if you have dark glasses I
feel like then yeah the reality was kind
of virtual because it almost seems like
when you have glasses on like that the
world is a little bit separate from you
yeah I mean when I walk around with
these I I can like stare at people and
they don't really I don't feel bad about
it cuz I can't see it I don't know yeah
cuz they're skiing by you probably I
would assume that's
why um no but you always look so stylish
and so that's why I wore this nice
jacket too is nice yeah thank you um but
yeah we can take them off if that's okay
with you yeah sure yeah and they look
really neat
thanks
um yeah thanks for coming in thanks for
having me yeah it's a pleasure it's
really really cool um I've known about
you for a long time sorry if I seem a
little bit Ratt I ended up watching a
movie real late yesterday oh yeah yeah I
was watching uh well it's holiday time
you know so I was watching um family man
that's my favorite Christmas movie okay
have you seen it no really no my my
son's on a Home Alone kick right now so
yeah he really loves Harry and Marv like
yeah like to hear his little voice say
like I love Marv I'm just like this is
the cutest thing ever yeah I mean in all
shows he might lightly be considering
crime I think because Mar they're the
wet Bandits right yeah yeah I think yeah
I think it's the Tom and Jerry situation
where he like laughs at somebody falling
you know oh yeah yeah yeah I was
watching that sequence the other day and
it was it's so funny when he sets the
little race cars and then I just love
how they they don't get deterred though
they keep trying to get into the house
and do the dumbest stuff yeah I wonder
if people like Harry or Marv more huh I
don't I don't know I don't have Harry
was The Lovable one yeah that's Daniel
Stern right there he was kind of the I'm
a huge jesi fan so you are yeah I think
like my cousin Vinnie is one of my
favorite yeah my cousin Vinnie it feels
like is My Life currently oh really yeah
because my husband and I I mean my
husband doesn't look like Joe peshy but
he dresses like him in that movie like
with the cowboy boots and like the black
leather oh yeah like an Uber driver in
Tulsa kind of I don't know but we we
ended up um oh there's your husband and
kid right there yeah a they're so
handsome thanks but we ended up moving
to Indiana in the middle of nowhere and
it just uh it's kind of like weirdly
Fish Out of Water but not really like we
really I really do feel like we belong
there yeah but yeah so I always think
about um my cousin
Vinnie scenario yeah cuz he was kind of
in a rural area wasn't he yeah yeah yeah
yeah that movie was good yeah I like
family man do you have a favorite
Christmas
movie I don't think so I mean like
Nightmare Before Christmas I guess
that's kind of the
token goth Christmas movie I don't know
is true yeah yeah I think after uh
what's that movie that that what was
that what's the thing that all the goth
people do in town I used to go to it
sometimes Rocky Horror Picture Show oh
yeah yeah uhhuh or is that a goth thing
or is that not no I think it's like a
theater kid thing I don't know that's
what it is yeah yeah sometimes like the
goth kids would always get get kind of
grouped in with that like I remember
people would drive by them sometimes and
be like yeah have fun at Rocky Horror
Picture Show and they be like what so
maybe that's no one's yelled that at me
before
but um yeah did you see mcau culen was
just on the news yesterday got a star he
got a star yeah I don't know why that
made me so happy like yeah I don't know
why it took that long I guess he's like
the most like iconic child actor right I
mean if you think about it oh yeah I
think so yeah you know I try not to
think about children much that you know
cuz if I don't just for you know checks
and balances and all but yeah I love
Yeah he was the best it was interesting
kind of listening did you see a speech
that he made no but I saw Katherine
nohara was there and I love that that
support I think it's so cool yeah it was
really really sweet yeah I wonder I
think of that a lot about like childhood
actors like how can you play it real
quick if you can find it on Twitter it
was kind of interesting just because of
growing up in Los it seems really scary
place or the entertainment industry
seems like a really uncomfortable place
to grow up in um but yeah thanks for
coming in um Kat Von D really nice to
see you today yeah and so I just so for
some of my viewers that know right so I
know that you uh artist and a tattoo
artist and an
entrepreneur and um you started or
people would know you a lot from uh La
Inc and from a lot of your tattoo work
yeah and uh and that whole universe
right totally is that fair to say sure
yeah I think a lot of people know me
from the tattoo world and the tattoo TV
shows that I used to be on and stuff and
then I've done a lot of things along the
way and yeah nice and so now you've
moved out of Los Angeles right recently
yeah yeah how long ago did you move out
well I bought a house about two two or
three years ago um in in the middle of
nowhere in Indiana um and it was really
about the house I mean was about a lot
of things there's a lot of reasons
behind making such an extreme move but I
I love restoring old Victorian houses
and um in La I used to have a house that
was built in 1890 and this one was built
in 1874 so it's a second empire style
Victorian home and uh it was operating
as a bed and breakfast for for I think a
few decades and um my husband and I when
all like the lockdown stuff started
happening in California we just saw a
lot a different facet to to to where we
called home and we just didn't feel
connected anymore we didn't really want
to be there anymore and uh and so we uh
looked up rural rural towns and
different states and I feel like um no
one knows where this town is even my
friends in Indiana have like never heard
of it and so that was a really good sign
we were like let's let's let's find a
place where we can be kind of left alone
and we went there and we loved it and um
people say it's haunted but I haven't
experienced that um yeah well it's
haunted by you now it sounds like
because if it wasn't haunted I feel like
it kind of like now it's got its chance
you know because but also 1874 that is
so crazy especially in Indiana Indiana I
think had a lot of like I don't know if
they had like slave stuff up there
actually like um so our house was built
by Benjamin Franklin shank and he was uh
the hay maker of the town so his family
um made hay and they also owned a lot of
the steamboats and um it's called
Switzerland County because a lot of the
original settlers were from Switzerland
and what's really cool about um the the
shank family is that there's actually
underground tunnels that connected
through underneath our house so they
were pretty big advocates for helping
out yeah oh wow pretty cool so the
Underground Railroad stopped there yeah
that's cool yeah wow yeah I think I
could see you being in a place that the
Underground Railroad had stopped through
and kind of Hogwarts probably passed
through like definitely a thorough you
know love getting pigeon Hol right now
sorry sorry I love it I love it it's
good the only way I know how to like
accept things in the world is to Pigeon
them I think um so tough choosing cuz
that sounds like almost so much fun like
once you guys made that decision was it
hard to make that decision to leave Los
Angeles or no yeah we yeah it was almost
overnight too we were just like we got
to get out of here and um and you know
we have a son too and I think like a
little bit what you were talking about
before um just there's pros and cons to
everywhere you live you know I think
like La has some really beautiful things
about it I love my friends I love the I
think La has the best food um in this
country to be honest but um it's just my
own opinion yeah um and you know I like
the pretty things I think there's like
nice like where I'm at there's no
sidewalks like we just have like a lot
of dirt roads and that so um we don't
there's no Billboards there's no um Uber
nothing no delivery services we have
like one stoplight and a gas station and
it's I don't know I I prefer the the
latter you know yeah um but I go to La a
lot because we still have like I make
music my husband is a musician as well
so we fly back out a lot all of our
producer friends and stuff are there oh
nice yeah yeah I uh I when you say of
how it was interesting like once you
made the choice kind of that was kind of
the same for me like I've been living in
Los Angeles for maybe 16 years I think
and so I still have my apartment there
right just because it's cheaper than
going and even getting a hotel for when
I do go back um I know I when I go out
there now I stay with with Charro she's
my best friend and she um
she's nice enough to give us like a
little room in the back of of her house
and yeah it's it's I I look forward to
it I feel like um being able to see my
friends and stuff but uh but I also look
forward to kind of escaping and just um
you know having like a safe haven yeah
yeah yeah that's exactly how I felt and
once I made the the decision there was
actually a uh a friend that said you
should move to Nashville and I was like
I that's so weird and I talked to a
friend of mine about it an old friend of
mine and he's like dude used to talk
about that when we live to Nashville
yeah he's like when we lived together
you used to talk about that all the time
I was like really uhhuh I don't remember
it but I was like yeah and so then I
came here and before I knew it I had
moved and I was like oh my gosh I always
thought it was so scary to be able to
leave Los Angeles for some reason yeah
you know there it's like there's
something you're letting go of or giving
up on kind of but it's only been kind of
like a gift I think you know yeah are
you do you mean because of like the
entertainment industry or something or I
think you know that maybe that's it I
think you know I don't know I don't know
there's nothing really I I I kind of
decided there's nothing really that I
want out of Hollywood really which I
think is why I I'm I'm grateful that
there is a thing called that that you
can do do podcasting you can do your own
stuff and you can do standup comedy
where you don't really have to have a a
Hollywood involved really you know these
days um so what did you ask me I'm sorry
cat I don't know I don't think I asked
you anything oh
damn that's where I live right there A
lot of times like people were like yeah
I be talking people were like dude who
you talking to did you ask me something
like no dude they're like I'm just I
don't even know you and I'm like all
right then I'm just going to go get my
car and leave then um but I think no it
was interesting oh just moving and
making that choice and suddenly being
somewhere yeah did you guys look at cuz
you seem like a real you know like you
seem like you go some Realms on Zillow
that the rest of us aren't allowed into
true like I feel like you probably have
gotten some pass wordss well it's funny
because I do I like my real estate lady
in La like would always laugh because
I'm just like hey let me know if
anything interesting or obscure comes up
and it would be like just some of the
weirdest uh like I I know all the
castles in La there's not that many but
um and I used to live in one but um yeah
just interesting we yeah you're right
there are some oh yeah I think
definitely if there's a you know
anything that's had a missing person in
it or just like a you know they a found
femur maybe I mean one time I saw like
the uni bomber had his little Shack in
was it Oklahoma right yeah he had
Oklahoma City that was that was for sale
and I was like who who would it was in
the middle of the forest like I saw that
one for sale once you're like who would
buy that and then you like send it to
your husband like what do you think babe
like I don't know I mean but yeah people
some stuff is collector's items it's you
know
but yeah it's interesting because like I
like I always say like you know your
idea of a good time is my idea of a
nightmare you know and vice versa and
and I feel like you look at these these
houses that um to me I I love the
historical aspect and preserving things
of the past I like the human fingerprint
of um of Art in general like I you know
I have friends that are into like the
complete opposite they love the modern
stuff or you know or even 1950s or art
deco that stuff start it's cool but to
me I feel like I just I want every
corner to feel like somebody dedicated
their life time to it you know wow and
so I appreciate that a lot and um and I
like conserving that and um and
restoring it so so but then some people
would look at it and be like let's tear
it down and just you know yeah I think
that happens a lot yeah you seem like
somebody that would have like crown
molding in the top of their mouth
probably
yeah you know like you seem definitely
like you just are really ornate
I don't know if ornate is the word yeah
ornate a wonderful word orate yeah and
yeah I'm not trying to judge you but I'm
just judging you out loud and
clearly that's funny I never thought
about that yeah I always like to pige I
put people in like little spaces that
makes it feel M I don't know if it makes
it feel manageable I never thought about
that before I like it I mean it's to me
it it makes life a lot simple more
simple because I don't know like I've
only wear black I know it's it's a
choice I just like it and I remember the
day that it happened mhm like I had
these beautiful dresses that I had
accumulated over the years that I just
they were really colorful and I was like
I'm just never going to wear them why
like why am I kidding myself and I just
gave everything away and just kept I
simplified everything and now just I
just wear black and it's I I pigeon hold
myself into this
uh gothy corner I guess yeah but that's
that's yeah I like to wear black when I
do standup comedy because I don't like
to make a lot of choices like even this
to for me was making it took this took a
long time to figure out and and um yeah
and I just don't I don't know I don't
like making a lot of choices um but yeah
did you did you guys look at some other
places when you were looking for your
home um cuz 187 I mean that's an old
place yeah it is uh we we were looking
at different states and um and I think I
think Indiana was appealing to me
because I saw like the mass Exodus of
California happening and everybody was
moving to Texas Nashville and um I don't
know what the other places were that
they were I think those those two were
kind of or some Nevada I guess yeah and
I I just wanted to get away from as much
as I could from the California mentality
in general so I was like Indiana seems
safe like no one's going
there but yeah wow that's and and I like
like our little town is it's cool
because it's right on the Ohio River and
so the house is along the river are like
the prettiest you know cuz they're I
don't know I guess yeah cuz you got to
have money to live by of water usually
and then it's like then we have like our
little Main Street and it's just like
our our downtown or whatever is
literally one block long and then in
between that and where my house is on on
the hill it's kind of
like houses that could use a lot of love
you know and I just felt
like it no one's going to move here you
know like if they like Okay so you're
from in California you know like Silver
Lake and Echo Park I was around when
that was just super ghetto like you know
nobody in the right mind would move
there it's like it was actually quite
dangerous in some areas and now it's
like good luck finding a a tiny place
for less than $1.2 million you know and
so I feel like I've bought myself a lot
of time finding a place that's not going
to get changed yeah like I don't want
you know yeah yeah you don't want uh
yeah you wanted to get as far away from
that as possible interesting yeah what
were some scary parts about moving into
a house that old like what are things
that people do not think about I guess
um cuz that's old bro that's like that's
only I mean that's that's pretty old I
mean 1874 that you can't even really get
much older I don't think that would
before that I feel like not in America I
feel like there are some houses
from the late 1700s I guess but I don't
know when did people start using wood to
build houses
because at some point we evolve probably
from it's the regional thing really
because you know like on the East Coast
you don't have earthquakes so you can
have a lot more bricks oh it's true H
yeah so what's the most popular piece of
uh house building
material well it's expensive now just
because of inflation and everything oh
yeah these days dang you gota oh it is
thought the first wooden structure was
built over 10,000 years ago Europe's
Neolithic long housee constructed in
around 5,000 to 6,000 BC is an example
one the earliest freestanding Timber
dwellings huh so wow 5,000 6,000 BC so
that's like almost 8,000 years ago yeah
wow but I guess it makes sense dude if
you're standing around and you're cold
or something yeah and they got a lot of
sticks around if you don't do something
you're an
idiot I think no offense to whoever that
guy is you know but you got to like you
got to figure out dude you know there's
only so long you can just go like this
you know before you try to change the
game you know um oh the most common
Building Material in the world is
concrete wow is the most widely used uh
is the most widely used building
material in the world making it a good
starting material to get to
know um what did you guys have to do to
the home when you got there uh we're
we're actually still renovating it right
now so so actually we we we don't live
in it yet because it's um there just so
much work having to redo a house like
that um so we live actually at our
Church's parsonage so um the pastor from
our church lives in Louisville and so he
him and his wife will they drive up
every Sunday so they were like hey you
know there's just no place to rent out
there like there's literally no like
people people live there forever and
then they pass it down or sell or
whatever so um when we first moved out
here we're like man where are we going
to live and then they were just so nice
enough to let stay there oh that's nice
of them yeah yes so you're in a place
where there's like not even really a
real estate market yeah if you say
there's no Ubers like yeah yeah I was in
a town recently and I couldn't get an
Uber at night it was like it was like
what it's kind of a busy but it was like
I guess everywhere doesn't really have
it yeah no no not not where we're at
yeah yeah um would have been some neat
things about being out there like in
just
that um well I homeschooled my son and
so it's I like that um Indiana has um
they're very supportive like the state
of Indiana is very supportive to
homeschool families and stuff so that
was a very big selling point for us and
why is it hard to do is there like a lot
of Regulation with it some some states
and different places have different yeah
so I'm to me I'm like the less
government the better so I was like you
know that's that's a one of the perks of
the state of Indiana and so um so yeah
like I my my son just turned five um
last week so we're you know getting it
ready to start like uh first grade yeah
what I know it's so cool wow and so you
like have to redesign the room for like
the learning room or whatever each year
to make the grade seem different or um I
don't I mean right now he's like we're
not doing crazy curriculum because he's
just turned five so um but once we get
into the house I do plan on having like
a little school room area but that's the
cool thing about homeschooling is that
you can teach anywhere really um I feel
like the idea of putting your kid in a
you know like a like a school or a
classroom setting it's I think that's
kind of people are tending to steer away
from that in a lot of places so yeah
well it feel some of it starts to feel
dangerous too it seems like there's a
lot of violence schol in schools it
seems really like but I don't know maybe
that's just like the algorithm like for
some reason sends me those videos
sometimes but it seems like there's like
a lot of violence in schools but I don't
know it's one of the reasons why I chose
to live in Tennessee it's very safe or
in Nashville it's very safe here yeah
it's super safe yeah and
um yeah but I don't go to school anymore
so I don't know what it's like really
same I didn't go to I didn't go to
school you didn't I I started tattooing
when I was 14 years old and then I I
remember the first time I ever did a
tattoo I'm like this is what I want to
do like I I already I just knew it in my
heart and so I was like why would
I spend so much time in school when I
don't need to you know yeah I not that I
would condone people dropping out or
anything like that but it worked for me
and I oh people will do it without you
cond
a lot of people are just don't like it
or they're not even smart and they don't
like it um do you your family started in
your family cuz you were you're from
another country your family from another
country yeah so my family is from South
America from Argentina and I was born in
Mexico and then I moved here in the 80s
what were they doing there my dad was a
missionary for the church so they were
he's like long line of um like
missionary doctors and so he was
building um hit Hospital in like little
pitos that didn't have any hospitals and
um and then my my me and my siblings
were born there so it was it was pretty
cool upbringing I loved it yeah um we we
came from nothing like literally nothing
really yeah we had like dirt floors and
no running water and it was like truly
third world with wow it's cool and
you're from ncwa my father's my father's
from there my father my my father's my
grandfather I guess was a missionary oh
really yeah and they were down in in uh
Nicaragua and that's where my dad was
born cuz that's where my grandfather I
guess met his wife or something and then
that's where my dad was born at um and
so he grew up there he used to tell me
stories about kids in his village that
would that would eat dirt actually and
they didn't have anything to eat and
they would eat dirt and their stomachs
would get like all distended and stuff
like he would tell me some kind of crazy
stories but um but yeah that's
interesting yeah there that that they
were missionaries down there as well and
then so then your family moved up to
America yeah yeah we came up through
Texas and then moved to a little town in
Southern California called Linda when
you say came up through what are we
talking about I'm like driving okay we
just drove through I okay I I was still
I didn't have my papers yet because I
was like underage okay I was going to
say if the d stands for
deportation no I wasn't through like I
wasn't in the trunk or anything like
that it would have been so you to be in
the trunk though I feel like like just
like in some mysterious is the reason I
look like this
now you're like this is the closest
thing I can find of a
coffin hey this coffin's got a tire in
it that's funny yeah ho ho ho boys and
girls get ready to
Jingle and protect your holiday balls
with help from our
friends over at manscape they help your
balls baby they'll do it they can do it
the leaders in below the waist grooming
have just launched their performance
package 5.0 Ultra but I like to call it
the small gift for your big package
boys that's right let your ornaments
shine and enjoy 20% off and free
shipping at manscaped.com with code Theo
the performance package 5.0 Ultra is the
One-Stop shop for Holiday gifting
Perfection get 20% off in free shipping
with the code theom manscape.com
that's 20% off with free shipping at
manscaped.com and use code
tho give the gift of manscaped this
holiday season cold turkey baby that's a
meat and it may be great on sandwiches
but uh there's a better way to break
your bad habits we're not talking about
some weird mind voodoo from your crazy
neighbor we're talking about our sponsor
fume and they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of a drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your
habit that's fume fume is an Innovative
award-winning flavored air device that
does just that instead of Vaper fume
uses flavored Air instead of electronics
fume is completely natural and instead
of harmful chemicals fume uses delicious
flavors start the holidays off right
with the good habit
by going to trif nume.com
Theo that's TR r y fm.com
[Music]
slth EO and getting the journey pack
today fume is giving listeners of the
show 10% off when they use code Theo to
help make starting the good habit that
much easier were your parents what were
your parents like did you guys have a
fun family growing up what was it like
yeah I mean it was pretty modest
upbringings you know um went to church a
bunch we didn't have a lot of money but
my dad and mom they had a a piano and so
all of us were trained like classically
trained in piano since I was five and so
I've always loved music music has always
been like my biggest passion I like I
like classical music because that's what
I was kind of brought up on but um but
now I make like more electronic like
synth wave 80s style music oh sweet yeah
um but childhood was was good I have two
siblings who I don't talk to anymore
they actually live in this state here
really you don't talk to them uh-uh no
way no interest in it really yeah wow
wish them well though but yeah yeah I
have one that we barely kind we don't
really yeah talk much anymore it's weird
kind of huh yeah it's strange yeah
family is funny you know but yeah it's I
think it's interesting because it feels
like a lot of
responsibility but it also feels like
the only people that maybe will have a
lot of the same in like
that shared some common information I
guess and shared like some common
experiences I don't know I think it's
interesting to I think a family is
something you really have to build and
has to be put together pretty well by
the by the parents a lot of times yeah I
mean I can watch a movie and I see like
people who are close to their moms or
their siblings and and I can understand
it but I can't really relate as much and
I I probably will sound a little bit
cold but I just feel that there's you
you feel a sense of obligation because
you're related to somebody by Blood but
I think think it's kind of the opposite
where like or what you said where you
have to work at it if you really want it
to you know be a a good relationship
like any relationship you know yeah but
like I look at my husband's family and
like they're just so cool and so warm
and wel welcoming and just like like oh
like oh I didn't have I don't I don't
have that that's okay you know was it
just uh yeah because I think about
family stuff a lot you know I think
about that kind of stuff and like how
does it affect you as you get older and
stuff um I'm really close with my dad
and I'm trying to talk him into moving
out with so oh really yeah that would be
my dream is if if my dad could like live
on the same land with us does he have a
cool Spanish name or uh or uh or like
like his real name Central American name
or no his name's Renee Oh Renee it's
like a painter huh Renee Carlos yeah oh
yeah he's in dude yeah oh I'll buy look
I'll buy a 28 by 12 from him know it's a
unique shape for art but I'll take it
you have Renee Carlos to yeah oh for
sure that's beautiful yeah yeah I think
if you're Spanish you can have kind of a
little bit of a woman's name and they
let you slide more yeah I like I feel
like there's probably a lot of Italian
renees right yeah for sure yeah yeah
they definitely get away with being a
little bit more of a woman in the name
you know my dad's like the opposite of
that he looks like a 1950s like boxer oh
he does dude yeah cuz if I was like yeah
this is my buddy Sarah right here a lot
of dudes wouldn't people wouldn't be as
as accepting I don't think in America
yeah um so your life now so you moved
out to Indiana you liveed there oh one
neat thing I saw on your Instagram was
you have this pretty crazy Tulip Garden
did you grow it yet so yeah so I got um
there's like this plot of land right in
front of my house so people know where I
live like once once like they found out
that I bought the property was in the
news and stuff and so and also like the
shank Mansion is kind of like famous on
its own because of like all the supposed
haunting I I haven't seen anything you
know but why do you squinty I'm just
thinking of what it's going to be like
when the ghosts show up over there I
just you know I've never seen a ghost
and I'm not saying that I have tons of
friends that are have like solid you
know like they're stable people and they
have seen things and experienced things
I just personally haven't so it's hard
for me to you know I don't know you
don't believe in ghosts you think well I
don't know if I necessarily don't
believe in it I think like I just
haven't experienced anything and also
I've lived in old houses so like they
make noises all the time and I think
that a lot of people want to like
experience it so they like that's why
they have like Haunted Tours and things
like that but I don't know I just feel
like I haven't seen it but yeah people
want there to be somebody else like I
think some people are lonely too and so
they want a ghost to be around like
there was this
like these two guys that like when I
bought the house cuz I Googled the house
to see if there's anything that came up
and on YouTube there was like a like a
house tour that these guys did they like
rented out the bed and breakfast but I
don't know if they told them they were
they were going to film and they were
just like kind of dressed I don't want
to say goth but like just older
gentleman and um they were just like
really wanting to catch some Paranormal
Activity and it's so bad like there was
it was like dust in the air and they
were like did you see the orb you know
and it's like there's no there's nothing
there you know but uh but I I don't know
I haven't I haven't experienced any
anything there but the shank Mansion
there it is yeah y house was restored in
2000 Opera a bed and breakfast is a list
of national register of historic places
in 2002 oh look it says that I bought it
yep so that's cool yeah well oh so back
to the Tulip thing so so there's this
plot of land that's right in like right
outside our gate and um and it's just
it's just grass and the lady who sold me
the house she owns it my friend Lisa and
um so I I hit Lisa up and I was like hey
look I got a bunch of tulips and um I
thought it would be cool just to just to
bring something to the community you
know just have CU people are coming here
to take pictures anyway so why not give
them something like really cool to look
at and so I got 10 th000 black tulips
and I thought like this is going to be
an enormous like just a field of black
tulips BTM 10,000 is a lot and then we
did the math and the square footage is
like it's not that big like I feel like
it's maybe twice the size of this room
the tool of the what 10,000 of them oh
that's all it makes yeah because you
plant them about three three to four
inches apart a so I feel like I guess
they don't want to be far away from each
other yeah so we that were a little bit
more like spread out yeah or just like
they're cool with kind of doing their
own thing I mean apparently tulips are
kind of like I guess they're I guess
they get Lonesome or whatever yeah or
you know whatever it's called I don't
know what the what that would be like as
a flow like what it yeah so we'll see
we'll see we have like
um you know Wildlife out there and
everybody in my Instagram was like you
know be careful cuz the squirrels are
going to eat they're going to dig them
up or the mol so we're hoping that by
the time spring comes they don't eat all
of them but dude if you had an only fans
of you just fighting
moles I would I think a lot of people
subscribe to it I mean I think you get a
lot of the hunting audience you
know how do you fight a mo though I
don't know that's up to you I think but
I think it would just be pretty
fascinating to watch um is it do you
feel different being out of La what does
that kind of feel like does it feel like
were you kind of done with entertainment
I mean you've had a you've had a neat
career and at least gotten to experience
you know certain things you know like
that's that's one thing about having a
different opportunity sometimes at least
you get to experience what it's like
whether you whether it was great or you
didn't like it you get experience you
know yeah I mean I'm still I haven't
retired yet so I mean I feel like um
like you said you know the the beauty of
being able to create and do things you
don't necessarily have to be in La
anymore and so I think before you used
to I feel like you had to live in LA if
you needed if you wanted to do things
but
um but now it's like I mean I make music
so I I could do that from my house I
don't need to or I could fly in and
record or yeah I don't necessarily have
to live in Hollywood anymore yeah that's
nice huh yeah yeah um what else can we
think
about um so like did you know that in
the state of Indiana like you're not
it's illegal to to own a
squirrel um I found this out because my
my son found like a little a little baby
squirrel that had fallen out of a tree
and it happens a lot like squirrels fall
out of trees and stuff and um and this
one was like barely breathing and really
dehydrated I used to work at the
California Wildlife Center in back in in
California and so like rehabilitating
squirrels is pretty easy it's not yeah
it's not like a you know like a an owl
or something like do you need two hands
to do it or you can do it one hand
probably need two ants to do it huh yeah
two cuz you have to like feed them with
this little like syringe thing okay but
um so we rehabilitated him my son named
him lucky he's like the cutest thing
ever and then I um I I got baptized and
then I I got like a a bunch of criticism
about this baptism video so I had to
make this I didn't have to but I was
inspired to make a video like calling
out like judgmental Christians or
whatever and uh and in that video lucky
is just like just like flying behind me
he's just like running around and
somebody saw him and reported me to the
animal control and they they showed up
like the guy showed up with like a gun
and everything was like Hey do you do
you have you guys have a squirrel like
we you know you can't have one so we're
going to have to take it and I'm like
they put him in cuffs
now no no but they I so I asked the guy
I was like are you gonna euthanize him
because I know that's what you guys do
what are you you're not going to house
him and they're like yeah it's going to
get euthanized no are you kidding
me so they took him out of a warm they
take him oh you I lied and I told him
I'm going to release him the next day oh
cool and then we made like a little
Instagram video like of him leaving yeah
yeah we don't have to tell anybody if he
came back or
not you got it lucky lives
elsewhere wow dude that's incredible
like who would do that that's crazy so
so cruel well it's just also the just
the weird like how legislation is so
obtuse from like like there's no
intricacies a lot of times with like law
and rules you know it's just for this
General thing and so it's and they don't
have any room to ban a lot of these guys
who come to you know it's like they're
just trying to do the whatever the the
no I was just more confused by who who
in the right mind would be like oh let
me go and Report airrel yeah probably a
baby squirrel yeah
oh yeah I would feel so perverted even
reporting it or I would just be like hey
uh imagine that call like hey I'm not
trying to be a snitch or whatever like a
branch snitch or whatever yeah but
there's a scat as a
[Laughter]
squirrel I dude they should if you know
they release that body cam footage they
have to release that call that call you
should remix a beat to that call and
that you should make I wish they did
have body one of the best house songs
ever dude get squir get well the best is
like it was my husband that opened the
door and he was like topless with like
and he's like fully tattooed with the
squirrel on his shoulder oh well then
that didn't help yeah yeah people are
like people are trying to get this
they're trying to get this animal and uh
M squirrel 13 over here like there
there's not this bad stuff's going on
out
here um yes so what how did your journey
go to like I don't know if I want to
call it a journey but like what was like
what like role has religion like played
in your life and stuff because um you
know I think as we're at a time in the
world I think in just in I think we're
always at a time in the world but I
think we're it feels like a lot of
people are looking for something that
makes sense more I feel like we're
getting
exhausted like by the truth that a lot
of the things that we feel like will
make us feel good aren't doing it you
know um I feel like that a lot of times
but um yeah what what what has some of
that experience been like I mean if you
got baptized they really
how what kind of uh and was it like uh
what do they do with in what do they
baptize you in water oh yeah yeah good
huh oh here's your video right here oh
yeah oh it's pretty there
[Music]
huh upon your profession of faith in the
Lord Jesus Christ and in obedience to
his Divine command I baptize you you my
sister in the name of the father and the
son and the holy spirit amen oh
congratulations thanks I still get teed
when I see that that's cool it's
powerful yeah yeah how what is that like
in your
life yeah
um what's it like how do you get there
like how do you get because I think a
lot of people are lost I feel lost a lot
of times you know I think a lot of us
feel that way and so how to you feel
like you solved like you're
lost um well I mean or is that even a
fair question I don't know yeah I know I
get what you're saying I I I was brought
up with um Christianity in in my
childhood and and then I strayed and uh
so like in a nutshell I just kind of in
the last five years have like made my
way back and have a a different
understanding than maybe when I was a
kid because I think when you're a kid
you're like or at least for me it was
like we just go to church because that's
what we have to do and um
you know I don't I didn't
have actual profound questions that I I
want answered like I do now and so I
think as an adult you get to have a
different understanding of that and so
that that's kind of what you know how I
in a a weird artsy way just kind of came
back and I just the last five years have
just been studying the Bible and um and
now like at this church like we have our
Women's Bible study and stuff that I
that I attend and um
you guys have a meeting you go to right
I I watched another podcast that you
were on oh yeah yeah oh yeah um I heard
you talk about it anyway that you guys
have a Bible study each week yeah yeah
um and you know I think I'm I'm going to
always have questions and continue to
want to learn and have deeper
understandings of things and so but I in
that podcast that you probably watched
like I talk about like a little bit what
you you said it's like we're trying to
find meaning or um want to feel again
you know and they think they're there's
a lot of temporary fixes or you know um
like you know I used to like I was an
addict and you know I'm so I I'll have
uh 17 years sober in July wow and so you
know I think I feel like those are all
things that kind of like lead you in
that in that direction and yeah I think
you know it's such an intimate and
personal thing like my relationship with
God is my own and um and I I've never
really felt like I belonged anywhere um
like
especially now I think like being public
with my faith um puts you into like this
microscopic um critical tank you know
and so I get criticized from from all
sides now which I don't care because at
the end of the day I I'm you know my
relationship's with with God not you but
right but it is interesting I feel like
now it just becomes funny like some of
the comments I get yeah I think cuz
people have a hard time understanding
the aesthetic and pairing that with
something which is your aesthetic you
mean yeah right the Ambiance of you and
then comp and then pairing it in
Christianity and it's so silly to me and
like I I don't understand how people
don't see how um close-minded that is
you know and how like yeah why would you
think that you have to look a certain
way to to have an understanding of the
Bible you know yeah or you know yeah
that's a good point too I think it's all
well a lot of that there's a lot of
interestes and stuff there you know yeah
like like I do but you know so I mean
there's a lot to think about in all of
this yeah for sure you know like one
time I went to like a Jordan Peterson um
uh lecture and my husband and I were
like the only people that looked like us
there um but I was black people you mean
what you mean black people no we
just I just like and I don't want to
diss on like Jordan's fan base but I
feel like there everybody had their own
uniform you know like there was just
rows of people in front of me and they
all kind of dress the same really yeah
and I was like man for some for people
who and I'm not again not judging or
criticizing but you would think that
like free freeth thinkers would I or
maybe they just don't care I don't know
or maybe there's just only so many
stores too where you can I mean I feel
like you it's a lot of Johnson and guys
who like are s like I don't know I'm a
Jordan Peterson fan but I'm like I think
it's a lot of like there's you know it's
a lot of uh Lost Boys but who have and
uh who can uh
comprehend well or well enough you know
cuz otherwise Lost Boys who can't
comprehend they kind of you know they
listen to maybe um huba stank or
whatever you know but I think if you get
or uh or hey hey come out and fight
remember that song you got to keep them
separated oh yeah yeah uhhuh oh
Offspring Offspring yeah dude yeah so a
lot like yeah if you are a lost boy who
can't communicate as well as you'd like
to sometimes and this is a judgment but
you probably have owned an Offspring
album and then if you were a different
version then it's sometimes Jordan
Peterson um but yeah I could not imagine
see it would be like playing where's
Waldo if I saw you at a Jordan
Peterson
concert so that's interesting but that's
awesome that you guys went and you found
like that that what the oh so I so my my
my whole point was just that I feel like
uh maybe we pigeon hole ourselves right
like I feel like everybody kind of like
I went to
this like so the church I go to is like
a really small church and it's it's
there's not enough people to have a a
running Trend or anything like that but
when I went to like a big church in
California recently I looked around and
it's like a lot of people have the same
same style and so I realize that maybe
because um like modern day Christians
are so used to being surr surrounded by
people that look the same as them when
someone like like me comes into the mix
it's like oh wait this is demonic or
this is because I get called demonic a
lot or um or this is like you know
you're serving two masters and I'm like
I I don't think any of that is accurate
you know I I don't think you have to
there's no dress code to to be a
Christian there like um oh that's
baffling to me yeah but I get it a lot
like I just recently posted this the
like my last post was just a
I thought was like a very cool like
modest image of me like in a in a dress
and some funny shoes and I just oh the
comments are just hilarious it's just
people like Satan's G to bring you home
and just things that's
crazy y i I guess there's all levels of
everything like even if you get into
like the Christian like if you like like
I thought I was going to get hate from
my existing fans you know like just
people who are like feel like you could
be a deserter or something or maybe
people that are fans of yours that uh AR
don't have a religion or aren't
Christians or something that they would
have a thought about it and no they've
been super loving and open-minded and I
love that you know but it's been the
other the other side that I was just so
surprised but wow yeah you know that's
it's
like I think there's a lot of like
interesting stigmas with Christianity I
guess like I look I like religion right
I like um I don't know if I care what
religion people are yeah you know I I
think I wish I knew more about some of
the religions you know um I probably
prefer Christianity for myself yeah
because that's what I know the most yeah
and but or I would say that I prefer God
that's that's the term I like to use and
most of my belief
started um through AA through Al through
going to 12ep meetings it was like the
first time I ever like started to get
like an understanding of um like
starting to build a relationship with
God and talking to God and feeling like
that if I think or feel something that
there's something on the other side of
the universe that hears it or cares
about it right um and that it blew my
mind dude
because you know I've been like I've
been electrocuted a couple times
whatever oh yeah but I never uh had a
feeling like this it's not like being
electrocuted it's just like feeling like
wait what do you mean you you've been
electrocuted yeah I've been electrocuted
dude I've been electrocuted yeah I mean
not I guess a handful of times or
whatever yeah yeah I guess one time I
got electrocuted at a carnival when I
was young I got elect oh four three
years ago I stepped on I was walking
behind a h a t uh food truck and I
stepped they had a plugin a big joint
plugin and I stepped right on it and
just it
just you know I yeah yeah I wasn't it
was like the opposite of being baptized
I think it was not it was uncomfortable
but yeah but I was yeah but um I uh yeah
I like thinking about God I love
thinking about it now yeah you know I
was just asking God this morning just to
help me um just to help give me some
better Direction in my life you know
yeah and help me with the few things
I've been struggling with like I've been
struggling to quit vaping right so I
don't want to vape and so it's just been
so hard and like I'm an addict you know
it's like dude I will wake up in the
middle of the night and like see if
there's Vape places open and stuff and
then some [__] stay started stay
open in 24 hours oh yeah like cigarettes
was the hardest for me I love I oh my
gosh I love smoking yeah I love
cigarettes um but I I just can't I don't
want to be that that Mom like well it
became my go like vaping became my
higher power in a lot of ways like if I
have an uncomfortable thought feeling
moment whatever let me hit this thing
yeah and so I realized oh this is the
thing I'm serving this like yeah whether
I want to have a higher power whatever I
want it to be yeah this is whatever I am
serving this thing I show up when this
whenever the little like Ping goes off
inside of me I show up for this thing
that's crazy um yeah I I my life
revolved around smoking too and it's
funny because um you start like treating
it as like little treats like I would be
tattooing and I'd be like all right I'll
just get through like two hours and then
I get a treat and then you know you get
these little breaks and stuff and then
but then everything like life becomes an
inconvenience for at least for me um
I've never talked about this before by
the way like I feel like um usually when
I talk about like subbing and stuff
you're talking about like drugs and but
cigarettes were the hardest I mean it's
I just I love the ritual of it I love
the smell like like leather jackets with
and cigarettes to me is like so sexy I
just I oh Sam Elliot in The Mask have
you seen him in that no was sh remember
in that movie oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I
was thinking the other mask yeah yeah I
wish Sam Elliot was in that one too I
like Sam Elliot I mean I don't like him
like I like him but I like him yeah yeah
but um yeah people don't talk enough
about that it's yeah it's so I mean it
just the all of it is yeah I mean I was
like two packs a day whatuh for like
till recently packs Von D huh that's
crazy dude two packs a day you're lucky
you look so lovely still after haven't
smoked that much I know yeah true true
not not not I know I mean like but no
it's a b yeah it's like that's fortunate
you see some people that are just like
yeah some people look like they start to
eventually they they look like the
inhale that they take off a cigarette
they're just
like like like their whole just like
yeah you know yeah it's but if I see
people doing drugs and movies I just
instantly get like sick to my stomach
I'm like I just like the idea the idea
of doing drugs again is like I'm beyond
that but if I see somebody smoking a
cigarette I'm like man like I still have
that in like I can't I I can't um cheat
on that like yeah oh I stopped at a dude
this is the saddest story I remember
kind of Milling around a high school to
see if some kid was vaping after school
one day when we were and vaping so not
cool like that's the one that's like I'm
like why just smoke a cigarette like why
would you it's like so like steampunk
like with your little things DB dude the
steampunks are the craziest about
they're like putting together assembling
like it's so weird just get a cigarette
and be a
man God I didn't I didn't know that was
such a loser right
now but I'm okay this might be the
conversation I need that helps me yeah I
just didn't uh yeah but the yeah there's
some the people they put this they like
crank it and they make their own Vape or
whatever they like add vanilla seasoning
it's like they have a machine it has a
tumble dry setting on it like what yeah
these are the guys that are doing this
is a guy let's play that can we play
that let's see one of these yeah they're
the people that blow the smoke and they
what like there's there's team comp comp
like a guy you don't do any of that I
don't do it no this guy's out of his
mind this guy has a 12 gauge
Fai oh my God this guy this guy's wife
is
missing there's no reason to need that
much nicotine unless you did something
bad look at that this guy's a damn motor
in but the craziest ones are the
competitions it's almost like it's one
of those dog shows now it's like the guy
will blow a big smoke ring and then his
wife will like run and jump through it
it's like what is this [__] it just
anyway but it's hard it is it's hard and
I think since I don't have a family or
anything that I kind need to address
then uh I feel like I probably wouldn't
have quit if I didn't have yeah I mean
when I the minute I got pregnant like I
I got the plus sign I that was the day I
quit oh and then uh and then I started
again after I had my son not right away
but like were you hiding and doing it no
no [__] yeah no but I that's pretty
awesome that you weren't no no I mean I
never would post like I've there you'll
be hard pressed to find there's very few
photos of me smoking online but yeah um
but then when my son was two because I
had my little smoking Nook outside um
and uh he came out my son came he he
learned how to open doors you know and
he came out was like Mommy Mommy and
he's like what's that smell and I just
felt like such a loser I was like I
can't I can't be that Mom so yeah oh I
would hate that being that Dad what's
that smell it's like oh it's cranberry
lime crush or whatever is that your
flavor ice or whatever yeah whatever no
I prefer um watermelon lemon and
sometimes I do watermelon lemon mango if
they don't have the one that I like but
it's like it's sad it's all pretty sad I
think uh and the guy knows me huh he
calls me big boy when I walk in
there that's the worst part and he's
like kind of like a he's hispanic or
like Egyptian or something he's like
what's up big boy that's what he says
every time I go in there dude and this
is the saddest part I will buy it hit it
a few times and then throw it away so I
don't hit it anymore and then you have
to buy it again and then I'll go later
on that day and buy it again oh I was
just like I would just buy cartons I
just buy cartons cartons you buy a
boatload you'd be out there like on the
Ohio River like flagging down i' bu
cartons and then I like my big one of my
biggest pet peeves was like when people
would ask to like bum a cigarette why
you have a cart well yeah but I've been
Prof like I'm averaging one every 30
minutes I don't have a spare like why
would you do that like just go buy your
own there's some famous comedy Duos out
there baby Tom and Jerry Ricky and
Morty um buzz and Tony or I don't
remember the other guy's name but
there's a lot of great comedy Duos what
about the perfect Duo when it comes to
Growing your business that's you and
Shopify Shopify is the global clber
platform that helps you sell at every
stage of your business whether you're
selling scented soap or offering outdoor
outfits for the
outdoors Shopify helps you sell
everywhere from their all-in-one
e-commerce platform to their in-person
POS system wherever and whatever you're
selling Shopify got you covered sign up
for a $1 per month trial period at
shopify.com
Theo all lowercase that's right go to
tho lowercase now to grow your business
no matter what stage you're in
shopify.com
Theo I've had a frustrating time buying
tickets you know you don't you don't
know if there's enough in the zone or
you don't know if um the the price that
they say is exactly what you're going to
pay well game time is the fast and easy
way to buy tickets for all the sports
music comedy and other events near you
that's right game time offers last
minute tickets Flash Deals and Zone
deals game time is the only ticketing
app that gives you complete peace of
mind with your purchase you can see the
view from your seat before you buy so
you know exactly what to expect when you
arrive download the game time app create
an account and use code weekend for $20
off off your first purchase terms apply
again create an account and redeem code
we k n d for $20 off download game time
today last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed this episode is sponsored by
better help if you have struggled with
your mentality your brain your thinking
your process I had a friend recently
tell me hey man I think I'm not
associating to the world like I used to
and I said well that's okay man I think
I've been there and I think you can get
some
help and now he is getting help for
himself better
help they can be the go-to for
you that's right if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no add additional charge
visit better
hp.com Theo today to get 10% off your
first month that's better
hp.com EO that's how it was when I was
when I would do drugs too like I I
remember in the beginning it was like
fun party time you're out with your
friends and then the minute that I
realized like oh no this is mine I would
just start doing drugs by myself oh yeah
me too yeah like that was it like no no
sharing cuz there's so many preloaders
yeah and I was one of them first of all
and I'd finally gotten some drugs so the
last thing if I'm yeah it's finally time
I get to freeoad off myself you know but
yeah I would go home I would get cocaine
I would go home and just do it by myself
and it would be sad yeah oh yeah it was
the saddest man uhhuh I don't know why
but yeah people do that but yeah I think
a through a through like going to 12ep
meetings is where I started to build a
relationship with higher power and
really believe in one before that I just
never had it presented to me in a way
that felt uh I don't know that uh that
it that it like messed you know yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think that's important
I think is how you how it comes into
your life too you know a lot of times um
yeah and I just like having her power I
like having an invisible friend that um
yeah I like having an invisible friend
yeah yeah I feel like um I came from the
the school of thought where you know you
have to be like empowered and um you
know just believe in yourself and all
this the this idea that you do you know
it's kind of almost like self worship
and um and I think in AA you know they
they do talk about that where it's like
that you know you can't do this on your
own and I think taking that to like the
bigger picture part of it um where not
just with addiction that for me I'm like
I've definitely surrendered to that and
I don't think there's anything wrong to
you know to humble yourself and be like
I can't I can't do this on my own and so
it's kind of where I where I you know
landed I guess yeah yeah well I think
that's the part I struggle with a lot
sometimes is just on a daily basis like
turning my will over to God you know
turning my will over to a higher power
like you know I pray every day and but I
just I know that it's a relationship
that I want to be stronger in my in my
life you know I can feel it all the time
like me just wanting like a stronger
relationship yeah um and then yeah one
thing I like and I liked one thing I
liked about churches was just the sense
of community or you know religious
places people meet up worship centers
was just the sense of people doing
something together um kids being able to
do like Sunday school or whatever and
you going the back and you you know you
you back there everybody's like making
little arts or whatever and uh I like
that I like that sense of community I
think it was good probably for
communities to have some shared meeting
space and I think churches and religious
worship centers used to be that more
yeah in America you know I don't know
what it's like in the rest of the world
but um yeah I love that Community I love
I I personally love like I look forward
to my Sundays and we do like church well
we do practice on Thursdays and like I
definitely feel um I mean I think
because we have a small Church which I
think is a good thing like um when
people are missing like they're you know
when they go out of town or like they're
they they're missed you know like I feel
like I I genuinely miss my my church
family when I'm in LA or whatever oh
yeah that's cool yes it's I've never
really had that before and I I'm I'm not
that kind of person either like I don't
like group therapy I don't like doing I
don't like communal seating at
restaurants like I like Lone Wolf you
know yeah but but where I you know I
have found my little my little I guess
tribe whatever no that's fair yeah well
I think there used to be a lot more of
that I mean there's even that book by
Sebastian younger I think it's called
tribe maybe where yeah it was about that
it was about when we were in smaller
groups and stuff like that and people
used to yeah you would miss somebody
they'd be gone it's like otherwise you
get so caught up with so many things and
the your space gets too big it's hard to
know it's hard to pay attention it's
hard to connect you know or you're
trying to connect to too many things you
know and people feel like that's part of
it we're just trying to connect to too
many things I don't think our system is
built for that a lot of times yeah so I
think it's nice I bet having a yeah a
place where you notice that somebody's
gone yeah that's pretty cool yeah it's
cool it's important I think it's
important for us yeah you know um yeah
what was it like when you did you think
you really had an addiction problem what
was that like like oh yeah I mean I was
like a big time user drug user Loser
yeah Loser yeah that's
fine no I mean you know I I'm like a
quick learner so it's not like I can't
I'm never casual about anything um so
it's like you know what starts off as
innocent and just experimentation turns
into like like my entire existence yeah
wow and I you know that that part of my
personality I've change I've managed to
change over the years too like I've
grown up a little bit more you know like
what part of it you mean well cuz I
think before when I looked at like my
relationships when I looked at
like just everything has to be in excess
you know and and now I'm like a little
more balanced did you ditch the the
jacket yeah I just took my jacket off
cuz I don't know if I'm getting warm or
not or I don't know if I'm just feeling
like if something's wrong with me I feel
fine I'm not going to faint I don't feel
like sick I just I was like do I still
want to have a jacket on
and Titus took action I guess you know
um yeah I think faith is just so
interesting I think it used to be
probably a long time ago people had to
have more faith because there wasn't
like your your television screen was
almost like the sky or the you know it
was like watching nature like if you
wanted to be watch the nature Channel
you had to go outside like you already
lived outside so you got to just look
you know it's like I think we're so much
more connected probably to the
universe and um I don't know I I think I
don't know I just think it's interesting
what religion is like and and some
people say that it's bad for people you
know that people call it like the opiate
of the masses you hear people say that
and um but I don't know I would I think
there's bad representations of
everything you know um I mean there's
like certainly bad representations of
people in AA you know like I always had
a hard time going to AA because I just
couldn't stand a lot of the people to be
honest and well that and also like I
just feel like they were never it was
never really Anonymous especially in La
like people go there as a scene like you
would go and it's like so and so was at
a meeting or yeah I remember I was going
with a friend and then someone like took
a picture of us like from you know the
back or whatever and post like man like
you know it's like my friend's trying to
get through something and then yeah you
know it's like this unnecessary
attention or or the worst would be
comedians like that show up and they
would speak and they're just like
practicing their really yeah oh it's
like the worst the worst I'm like um
this is why I
VAP at least now I have somebody to
blame it on but no I'll say this you
know what there is some things about
that that make uh people feel
uncomfortable you know I try to go to
meetings and share as honestly as I can
and um that's cool but it's sometimes
you know that part I'm able to get over
like if somebody hears something I'm
thinking or feeling feeling about cuz
that sometimes could be was a hangup for
me a little bit like you know if people
started to recognize you it made me feel
like scared I think a lot of times um I
mean it all helps and it all doesn't I
mean you know I feel like if it if it if
it inspires somebody to keep coming
that's cool too but you don't want that
to somebody's sobriety hinged on that
but and I think there's also it's like
it's like churches there's some that are
mega churches that are you know
preaching weird gospel and like and then
there's smaller ones that are are not or
whatever you know I think it's like
because I know there's meetings that are
much more private and like you
know you know it's not a scene or a
dating scene or something you know yeah
but yeah a is interesting though I think
it's interesting that yeah a is
interesting but then also you're like
well what this is why I'm here some it
sometimes depends on my attitude if I'm
in a good at good mood that day it's
like I don't care yeah but yeah one
there was a meeting in Las Vegas
recently where a guy was like kind of
filming like himself like with this
in the backgr and that made me I mean I
spoke up for myself and I asked him what
was going on but it was just some of
that stuff's a little bit weird yeah
it's to be to be you know but then
you're like
well yeah I don't know I but I love
going to meetings that that I really
like yeah I thought it was super helpful
that's good um I was trying to think of
something else with faith that we could
talk about you you want to talk about
that stuff more is it okay with you yeah
yeah oh I love thinking about it I don't
I don't have a lot of people on that are
that I guess that we talk about it with
as much I'm probably the worst person
cuz I'm not like a studied you know oh I
don't know anything about like the
history of it I mean I know that the you
know I know about the family in the
woods I know they had the Apple I know
one of the sons killed the other one so
things got a little hectic right out of
the gate you know but uh but there's a
lot of like the spe I don't know a lot
of the logistics you know yeah so I
think I wouldn't yeah that part I don't
know about but I just think about
feelings and stuff I like thinking about
that kind of stuff some of that is
intuitive too I feel like you know like
like there's parts of you
know I think there's like some some
things that are like ingrained in us
that you you can't really explain you
know like it doesn't feel good to harm
somebody things like that you know yeah
um but I don't know yeah but then yeah
it's interesting how that kind of stuff
happens in the world sometimes you know
I don't know I don't yeah but I think
and then people go well you know if is
why would God let that happen I don't
think off is that okay yeah for sure
that's fine just don't don't get a shot
of it because that's gross I hate people
do that I just want to do this I won't
I'm I don't even have my phone on me
okay oh but yeah we can blur them out no
you don't have to blur
[Laughter]
him yeah but I think sometimes people
want to blame God when it's bad and not
for the good stuff but I think you look
at like um I I always think like we're
human you know we we sin we were capable
of making mistakes and and we have free
will to make you know good and bad
choices so it's like yeah of course
there's going to be evil in this world
like but I don't I don't think God would
be the one to blame you know I would
there you still have to take
accountability for your actions you know
um it's a shame that that bad things do
happen to a lot of good people and
innocent people that's the way of the
world you know yeah I think that's
always been there throughout time you
know I I don't think God of God is like
a specific instance to instance type of
like landlord or whatever you want you
know leader you know or Champion or
whatever some people call him different
names but um I think of him more as just
this G of like I think of like of I like
to think of his view of us as like a
general energy more like it's just
something that's always there no matter
if even if things are horrible it's
there and if things are good it's there
you know um it's almost like this like
uh it's like
this code or something that kind of fits
to whatever you need it to be I don't
really think of it as like a like too
much of like a rigid thing so yeah I
guess I wouldn't blame God like if
something horrible happened I don't know
if I would take it to God I would just
be like that's what we do here
unfortunately in the world you know I
might talk to God to try and have
understanding and maybe I would blame
him and he would let me blame him you
know that's one of the things he does he
just lets you blame him you know that I
don't know I don't know I like thinking
about this though some of it's
interesting you know yeah yeah because
it's like yeah how do we and I don't
know if our brains can conceptualize
everything like we're only we only have
five senses you know yeah yeah I was
just talking to my buddy about this the
other day like dude we only have five
senses yeah that's not that many
dude a lot can be done with that though
huh a lot can be done with that no no
and look people are doing a great job
you're right I feel like there's
like parts of my brain that can't
comprehend the concepts of time you know
what I mean but um we just try our best
to get to get through that like I think
about like the story of Job in the Bible
like um that one is you know even if you
look at it um you know not literally
like where like job was this guy and I'm
going to just paraphrase it obviously
totally paraphrase and look if anybody
judges somebody for paraphrasing out of
the Bible dude we're not pastors you
know yeah for sure yeah we're just two
people sitting somewhere trying our best
to be alive in the universe yeah yeah
it's true okay but thanks um but you
know like job was put through all these
trials and all the worst things that you
could imagine happening to one person
and through it he
just maintained his faith and even at at
a point where even at at one point his
wife was like come on are you serious
like how can you still like praise God
when you're you know you're losing your
children you're losing everything we've
had you know and um now you're sick and
covered in boils and on the brink of
death you know and he was just like
praise God you know and I feel like a
lot of times you know through my Decades
of tattooing people and hearing like the
worst and saddest stories like oh yeah
just you know I I I was kind of known
for doing a lot of portraits and so I
would do portraits of people um their
loved ones who have passed or you know
their loved ones who inspired them
things like that and you just hear some
of the most heart-wrenching stuff that
like I can't even begin to imagine like
how you're still walking you know but um
but they still find a way you know and I
feel like that's like I want to be like
job in that sense you know because like
this the like the last few years for me
have been so rough like behind the
curtains you know I don't share all my
I'm not the type of person that goes on
Instagram and cries you know but it's
like you know we we suffer quietly
through things and we like um you know
no one's no one has a perfect life and
um but I'm still going to live in a
state of gratitude you know and I'm
still going to be like excited to be
here sitting with you today you know and
it's like the the world could be falling
apart and I'm still like I praise God
you know yeah um yeah it gives you hope
I think yeah that's the thing I think
that's I don't know I mean yeah I love
that yeah and we do all s it is
interesting how we suffer quietly huh
yeah I mean some some suffer loudly like
a dick but oh yeah like my freaking
neighbor's dog I think's not even
suffering and uh
but it's loud yeah
um but it's all going to be okay yeah I
think that's what God is to a lot of
people it's a it's a
real it's a it's like I would way rather
have hope me too than to not have it
yeah that's the thing it's
like and yeah I don't know I've just
felt God I've just felt God like same I
it was the only thing I could say it was
yeah you know cuz one time I was smoking
a bunch of menthols actually going back
to cigarettes but my girlfriend had
broken up with me and I was about to
just you know peel my skin off of my
body and feed it to something and I
wasn't doing real well and I was just
really doing real bad just on the inside
I was just and I just I mean I swear
this is crazy but I felt like something
literally just like put like a like a
big hand went around my heart and I
started to feel better um but I felt
like a it really felt like that which is
same yeah I had the exact same feeling
yeah it was weird and I don't really
talk about it cuz then you sound all
like oh I don't give a [__] people know
I'm B you know we're doing our best if
anybody thinks yeah that they they think
I know anything about God like any exact
low-key BTS information about the lord
they're out of their fing mind and if
they think they do too then they're out
of their F in mind I just am trying to
think out loud and feel out loud with
somebody yeah is that what that but you
had something similar yeah yeah where I
felt like like a hand like just kind of
um wrapping me in warmth and um and I
just I just uh had this feeling of
surrendering to it you know where I was
just like oh man like it's it's going to
be fine and it's not it's not me just be
like oh tell myself until like you know
like no like I had I had like a a clear
understanding that like you got me you
know yeah it's kind of
cool yeah yeah and well what's
interesting too for me is that I've even
taken my own will back so many times
since then yeah and that's the tough
thing I think that's where I want to get
more into like just my morning routine
is just like turning my just thy will be
done you know cuz then it just takes all
the pressure off of me it takes all the
pressure off of me to like feel like I
have to make everything okay or that I
got to make everybody okay or that I
have what what are those pressures like
what like I don't know I think I just
feel
uh I've always felt um like I'm running
late for
something I felt that my whole life like
I'm if I don't keep doing
more then I'm not enough
or you or like if I don't do I think I I
felt as a kid like if I don't do
something like I just wasn't seen my
mother my mother didn't really look at
me right and so I think uh I felt like I
have to be perfect if I'm not the only I
have a chance of being
seen is if I'm perfect you know and if
I'm not if I'm not like perfect then I
just don't have a chance to be seen you
know and
um yeah it makes me it makes me sad to
think that a kid would think that you
know um but I think that's how I felt
you know I think and I'm not blaming my
mother I think or my father you know I
don't know I don't know what their lives
were like but yeah I just remember like
as I've gotten older I've been able to
recognize that like man if I just that's
what you were feeling for so long you
know I felt like I always needed to go
do something to try and make myself
better so that I was enough same yeah
yeah to be seen you know yeah um so I
think
uh when I say yeah thy will be done it's
like just letting like none of that M it
does everything's okay yeah yeah you
know like no matter how you are if
you're good or bad or if you're not
doing your best if you're not even
like not if you're not even trying
really I feel like you should try yeah
but just that everything
is you're just not alone you know yeah
and so I think I I've always had a tough
time like letting people love me you
know really yeah it's been really really
tough like like in relationships or
something yeah I think I'm just I think
that muscle just wasn't built up when I
was a child with my mother and so I just
didn't I just have had a tough time with
it and so um I think the interesting
thing about having try through 12ep for
me has just been having some trying to
build some relationship or it's the
first time that I've kind of have really
let somebody into my life yeah is in my
negotiations with God kind of and I hate
to call them that but that's kind
of you know that makes sense though like
how much am I willing to turn myself
over to that somebody else is going
to that somebody else is going to be the
be with me you know even if I'm not uh
even if I'm not enough if or if I don't
feel like I'm enough for them to uh keep
me around you know anyway yeah yeah
sorry I it's a lot of Stu but no yeah I
think I yeah I had this uh this um
scenario this this uh last week when I
was in LA actually um where uh you know
I had this makeup makeup line for 12
years and it did really great and then
at one point I got a a bunch of backlash
and um and I ended up having to
like really like sit with myself and
figure out like what I want to do with
my life if I want to keep up this fight
of um like I mean I don't know there's
like contractually things that that that
I can't talk about anymore but but when
I sold my makeup line um I had to sit
there in a in a meeting with the
production company and um and lawyers
and stuff and I remember I just wanted
to like shut it down like let's just let
it go like I don't want to do this
anymore you know and they were like but
I think they they saw there's profits to
be made and stuff and so um in order to
buy me out like you know there was
negotiations and at one point and I was
always very fair about things I don't I
I I wasn't asking for you know
the world and uh and I remember at one
point
um uh this guy this old man with like
this balding old man with a a potato
nose alcoholic potato nose like looked
me in the eyes and told me you're not
worth anything anymore like and um and
those words and his voice like hot me
still even though I know it's not like
this guy's telling me what cool like you
know and um and I know it was just like
a leveraging point to whatever try to
give me as little as possible but so I
uh when I go to La I like this is one
thing that I don't that I that I do
complain about where I'm at in Indiana
is that there's no places to work out
and I I actually like it's it's good for
my health to work out every day yeah so
when I go to La I'll fly in and then I
just go to um I go to Barry's boot camp
where I just have a bunch of people
yelling at me to run faster and uh and
so but if you've ever been into like a
Berry's workout it's like there's no uh
talking and that's another thing I like
about it you just go you work out and
then in between um like you do like
floor work and then you have to switch
to the treadmill right and in between
that you you switch and so we're right
about to switch and I'm just sitting
there like this guy's voice gets in my
head I'm looking at myself in the mirror
and it's just like like uh you're not
worth anything anymore and uh I'm like
what am I doing with my life and I was
like on the verge of tears and right at
that moment this like blonde girl
just comes up to me and was like Hey Cat
really quick I just want to tell you I
think you're so amazing and I just like
lost it like and then she just went on
her treadmill and like went you know and
didn't see her again and I was like man
is I know it's not um this is the part
where you should blame God for like
these beautiful Divine like moments
where it's like man you sent this girl
like to me just to say like a few little
words that like just changed my you know
I I was just like so grateful in that
moment I like went back home after that
workout and I just went to my husband I
was like this girl just changed my life
you know and he was just like yeah why
are you even listening to that I'm like
I know and that was like years ago and I
just still like you know I don't know
what part of me and and it's probably my
childhood stuff where you know I don't
know yours but mine was
like constantly seeking validation
through through my mom you know like
that wasn't there and it's like um and
you know I've gone to like years of
therapy to like fix myself and stuff so
I'm not where I was before but before I
was like definitely like oh yeah like I
need to um do more there's not enough
like I there's so much I want to do that
it hurts and it's just like and it's not
it doesn't really matter if you have
like a sea of people that are like
cheering you on at the end of the day
it's like it's just all in here you know
but um yeah it's just it's crazy to see
it in real time now I feel like ever
since I got to this place that I am now
like with with my faith like I start
start seeing it in real time all the
time where it's like God's just kind of
diving in and being like cut that [__]
out like you know um but I don't think
it's ever going to go away though you
know yeah and that childhood stuff and
all that kind of like I don't suffer
from that stuff every day no mean it
just creeps in sometimes yeah sometimes
people sh you know they're like man you
seem like you need I'm like I'm I'm okay
yeah you know but it's still a part of
me that lives inside of me you know and
um and sometimes there's still like I
noticed there's a lot of feelings like I
never got to have feelings when I was a
kid I didn't know I was always in some
type of mode of
like I need to be like seen I need to
make sure my mother sees me so I'll be
fed just taken care you know whatever so
I ne so at that point you're not
developing any other feelings except for
like you know yeah like a stress yes and
so I think yeah but I think the first
time I've ever really been able to have
some sort of a even discussion of a
relationship in my life has been um
through recovery and through uh the
introduction of God that way cuz it was
like you get to choose your own God
right and I I've just chosen the most
common God that I know and and um the
one that I you know friends families
would take me to church and stuff and so
yeah and that's fine for me you know
it's um but I think a lot of that's
interesting yeah man I can't what gets
me is that somebody would even want to
work in a job where debating or nego
apprting for money is worth even the
value of saying something like that to
someone yeah that's the sickest part of
the world I mean it it worked I
definitely was like questioning myself
in that moment and was like maybe I
should just settle you know and it's
like you know but lesson Lessons Learned
I don't I
think everything turned out the way it
was supposed to anyway yeah you know but
that's a lot of La it's like you almost
have to hire sick people to deal with
other sick
of that and it's
like you know but that's the nicest
thing about being out of there I think
is having some semblance of uh like I
don't have a manager I don't have I
don't know I've simplified my life too
it's crazy and and a lot of these things
have just because you know I've been so
used to being in this little bubble
where it's like uh having the assistant
and the managers and all this stuff and
then it's like we move out here and I
was like I can't really I don't want to
bring a compound of people over here and
you know we had a nanny for example like
um and and you know I I wasn't blessed
with a very close family so when when I
had my son it's not like I had a village
of family that was helping us out like
it was just me and my husband by
ourselves and um and it's fine you know
we we can do it but then I I ended up
hiring a nanny who was like family to us
you know and she would just come from 9:
to 5 so that I could do all my work
during the day and then and then once we
moved out here it was like um I was kind
of like left alone and I was like man
this is actually cool being um a
full-time mom I know it sounds so dumb
to say that out loud but like where I'm
it's just me 100% of the time instead of
um having somebody help and uh I think
it's made me obviously a better mom and
um and but but you you realize like with
with less is sometimes easier um it's
definitely less complicated you know
like my life is definitely like I I let
go of publicists and all that stuff I
mean we we'll definitely hire like when
we when I have an album launch and stuff
I'll put together a team and we do
things but in general like I'm not
dealing with a sea of people anymore and
it is it is definitely liberating and it
feels like just
um there's just more benefits to it I
think like even when you guys hit me up
and stuff it's like I used to be like oh
yeah just let so and so hand I'm like
it's cool I'll just drive myself here
you know like um cuz Southern Indiana is
not that far from here and I'm like my
son and my husband we took a little road
trip you know oh nice yeah and then it's
just like like it's just easier that way
you know yeah oh yeah and these days
it's like I don't want somebody Fielding
something that does has no idea what my
interests are yeah or what who I or what
you know they may have some idea what my
interests are but they don't they're not
going to make the choices I you know
it's almost like a lot of that whole
world is built on this shell system that
you need somebody to help you be a human
you know um but these days a lot of like
people don't even believe a lot of stuff
in the Press nobody takes I don't
believe any of it like it's all TR it's
all a bunch of [__] uh SoundCloud rap
you know it's like a lot
[__] I mean if anything usually if I
see like certain headlines especially
with my friends I'm like you already
know the the the truth behind things and
I'm like oh like I I'll be more like my
first thought is to be like oh it's
probably the opposite yeah whatever it
is out there CU but I feel like do
people still fall for it now probably I
don't know I if look if you still fall
if you don't think that I mean there's
just so like I have friends it's like uh
who was my friend the other day was
telling me that there's some celebrity
that they pay a couple Grand or
something and then some the people show
up and take pictures of them and then
it's going to be in some tablet but it's
all set up and none of it's like it's
all for show none of it it's not real
yeah
like and it's like people will come out
with a brand and then they'll call their
friend in a magazine and like hey can
you say that this brand is amazing and
then their friend writes an article says
the brand is amazing and we don't even
know if the brand it's just like so much
of it is um it's just
uh valueless yeah because it's not true
yeah you know and I think that's the
thing is just trying to sort out what's
true and I think that's what we're all
trying to do I think a lot of times just
in our own lives even is like well what
do I really think or feel what's true
you know I think that's something I've
had a interesting time
um so I mean I I mean that I think
that's one of the reasons I've always
loved you and everything you do is like
there's a level of authenticity um and
it's like like earlier we were talking
about style and stuff and I'm like I
love your style because it's it's just
you're effortlessly doing it whatever
you like you know or unless there's a
lot of effort I don't know I mean it
took a while to stay in there like I
don't know if this is okay but I yeah to
wear that black coat cuz I know you like
black
stuff I love that I wish I could be as
Brave as you I think I did think that's
the reddest lipstick I've ever seen in
my life but it's kind of a nice
Christmas color too wait what do you
mean Brave I think it's just Brave to to
put this
on to be like uh like cuz I remember
when I was in junior high school my
friend Matt Shin he was like he was a
neat guy and his brother played
in a band and I don't want to say the
band was bad but the band was probably
had a unique sound okay okay so and
their name was like uh you know like um
shuttering like it was something crazy
you know like desperate victim or
something you know like
definitely like the the name of the B
was one guy was playing the drugs but he
was he was just [__] shaking with
anger so much and he had the sticks in
his hand and was just keeping some type
of a vague wooden metal falsetto and it
was just that's who they were you know
but so I would go sometimes and try to
be like and I would listen to like Blind
Melon and like [__] blind melon is
like the one
the all I can say is that my life but
they somehow rolled I guess they weren't
goth but they were kind of hippie I
don't know if we had gos maybe we had
one dude oh yeah Goths was different
sorry these were just kind of like like
the
yeah these are just kind of like like
violent hippies okay all right so that's
kind of the group I was in for a little
while was this violent hippie group and
then um but yeah the goth kids would
wear like those shoes that were like and
then but they had to wait till everybody
left to walk back cuz it was like such a
uncomfortable walk sometimes she like
why are those goth kids still hanging
out by the tree over there like always
in the trees it's weird there's even a
website I think it was called Goths in
trees and for some there's like a
fascination with like goth people that
are like in trees I didn't I've never
felt the feeling calling but I don't
know there's a lot of them yeah it's a
thing so go on there it is Goss and
trees right there let's look at a few of
them they all hang out that guy's not
that go yeah that guy definitely oh that
guy is goth dude yeah they all hang out
in trees I don't understand oh there is
something very Edgar alen Poe about
it you know CU they're because of r I
think so now this lady seems
like it's a thing I have never done it
let's see more this is fascinating wow
now that guy is goth yeah look they're
inside trees it's
weird I wonder if there's something
about it that feels good to
them to our
species yeah I could see it now this is
really interesting she brought props oh
yes she's a Sith uhhuh or Scythe or is
it Scythe she's a scythe oh wow yeah
these are gos on on uh in trees it a
tree house or yeah it looks like a treeh
house or zipline Goss on zipline would
be good
too but I love this this is really
fascinating y um I used to love when
there was some dope Tumblr Pages out
there that was fun wasn't it yeah but
wait you were going to get to that the
point where so you had the friends that
were in the band and yeah but yeah and I
thought I was goth but I wasn't I guess
yeah we would just like listen to like
skinny puppy or bands like you know uh
epilepsy lizard or some kind of [__]
like that and then um yeah that was it
that was about as go as kind of as goth
as I get but I was always marveled at
the people that could go full Darkwing
Duck you know like people like that
Darkwing Duck yeah I think the people
that like could be like whoa like this
person like how did they get to school
did they flew here themselves like that
type of I think there was something like
like interesting about it yeah yeah and
there was always like there's such an
Allure I think about that sort of woman
or yeah I would probably say woman more
because I think it's like
a there's something interesting
about a goth person what is it what is
it about goth people why is it like a
like the loose screws probably or what
is it like why do they what is like the
the the calling towards like is there
like a code of conduct or something I
mean there's got to be um some childhood
stuff right I mean I know for me I I
like I said I never felt a sense of
belonging even within my own family unit
um so I remember discovering music and
then not necessarily seeing myself but
um like there was a reflection of
emotions happening like when I I like I
Love The Cure and Susan the banshe she's
the pession and I think like lyrically
and just like this um the soul to it you
know I feel like a lot of people are
sensitive in that sense but and then
they just like take it to the you know
to the outward expression of that but I
don't know I I just I just like it you
know I always maybe that's it maybe like
way to be seen too cuz I guess it was a
outlier like I grew up in a small town
so but but it's kind of not cuz like
right cuz you have your own group then
like is that what you mean well I mean I
don't know I I'm not judging I'm just
looking at it I'm like it's just
interesting funny like even this morning
when I was getting ready I was like you
know I feel like I tend to dress very I
cover all the time like I don't I very
rarely show my tattoos at all I was like
you know I'm going to change it up I'm G
to go see Theo today and I'll just wear
short sleeved you know but I feel like I
would always get tattooed for myself
like I just like to look at images or I
like what it looks like with the
appearance of it um I in the middle of
nowhere in Indiana like I dress like
this every day like
and it's like but it's not for anybody
else other than why are you laughing I
can just see how many men got have like
pulled up back at home and like honey I
seen a damn Apparition down there that
damn this neighborhood's going to
[__]
so really I think there's something
interesting about or no there's some
look I think a lot of men I remember in
our town a lot of men would go and cry
over by the wind Dixie in their truck I
remember why I don't know why but we
would go ride our bike over
it was like a sad place like I think men
would just go sit over there and be sad
sometimes I remember seeing that but um
yeah I think there was something very
alluring about a goth woman to me it
seemed like a siren you know like in
that book yeah for Odysseus you know
what I'm talking about yeah yeah it
seemed that's what it seemed like there
was like something like what's going on
yeah this is different it's different
you know I think it's well it's Brave to
be different I think so that may be like
we yeah was an element of like this
feels Brave to me like I'm just
interested how somebody kind of leans
into that or how they you
know not that they're joining a group
but it's like what how does that kind
of yeah why does why does one goth you
know yeah I I mean I don't know I just
like what I like I think and I
just do more of that or do a lot of that
I guess yeah
yeah it's interesting I've never gotten
a you know I think there's maybe I might
have dated a goth woman at some point I
don't remember but I probably I think I
could have I think I did she didn't
write you a poem huh I'm sure she did
I'm sure dude I was in the French Court
the other day with my brother and
there's people there if you go up to him
they'll write a poem for you and your
and your friend that you're about you is
it funny or is it like a no it was like
kind of a nice poem okay they're like
okay tell us a little bit about yourself
and I was like oh this is my brother and
you know so you tell them a couple
little things you know and then you have
to stand there for about 11 minutes
that's the tough part you know because
they're on typewriters yeah yeah that's
and they're all sitting there sitting
there on typewriters like a row of like
four of them and everybody's just like
and there's like music playing like
people are playing the Street Music and
it was pretty awesome we had a great
time and yeah we got a nice little
Christmas gift there cool super cool
yeah it was real nice co but yeah they
had yeah I was oh I was in a class with
this lady she was she smoked a lot of
weed like her some of her I think her
she had discolored teeth from them
but um she was awesome she was like the
stoner teacher kind of her alleged
Stoner and we would write poems in there
all day so I think that's maybe where I
saw some goth were her teeth they were
yellow I think they had a tint to them I
don't want to yeah I don't want to call
you know I don't know she could have had
a I'm so self-conscious about my teeth
lately I feel like in pictures CU I wear
red lipstick all the time no I feel like
I'm looking at yours yours are super
white mine I'm not show anymore and I
was like I even Googled like why cuz I
brush and floss like crazy and and and I
quit smoking so I thought oh I'm going
to get white teeth it's going to be
amazing and then I just it's just not
happening and I don't know what to do
about it I don't want to get I won't get
the fake teeth that everyone's getting
now it's CRA everyone looks crazy hey
buddy they look so crazy every like damn
what have you been eating buddy
electricity huh what what the hell have
you been eating dude Dam you got gloss
finish teeth what's crazy is your teeth
look very nice I would yeah your teeth
wher than your skin no no your teeth are
so white nuh-uh yeah huh oh I guarantee
you not but this is look everybody
watching like these people have the
yellow as [__] teeth these
idiots
um I just w i I'll live with my yellow
if it means not having like chicklet
teeth whatever everyone has oh my mom
was always brushing her teeth and
putting on hand cream yeah oh our house
could be burning down but as long as she
was getting her hand cream on yeah yeah
it was pretty cool though actually
I think yeah it was just you know she'd
always have that hand cream Bo you like
to have it I think it was probably
calming to her too maybe to be doing to
to kind of do this with her hands I
wonder what my son's going to take away
from like that's your one of your little
core memories and I'm like I wonder what
oh what his will be yeah oo cuz uh he's
so sweet he he learned the word
ravishing now he's like this morning mom
you look
ravishing look
thanks you're like go get in that tree
for family pictures actually no dude
that would be a neat idea we do we do we
get uh we do a lot of family portraits
together and I like I love our little
family because we just we look like a
little family you know like my
son
he is not scared about like what I think
not scared but like spooky to him is fun
because it's what he's around you know
what I mean so his normal is a lot
different than like normal kids and we
get a lot of criticism about that too
cuz um you know he cuz he wears black or
he'll like I'm like that's what he likes
like at this point he sees his dad or
his mom you know it's like it's it's
normal to him so so we did like a photo
shoot for this uh it was actually for
like a an interview like for a magazine
thing and they wanted to shoot us in
front of our house and so I was like oh
there's like this little Fountain and I
had like my little like Tim Burton like
parasol thing and um and people just
hated it I think they just hated sing
like it bothers them that we we don't
look normal I don't understand it's
really weird I would think you would
think like oh that's cute it's very like
Adam's family or something you know well
even like we're saying earlier people
want to put and I I do it too I want to
have a box I want to have a safe space
for things to be and I don't want things
to I'm okay with the edges fraying but I
think there's a part of me even like a a
system of organization I think cuz your
brain just all your brain does is just
organizer it's just an organizing tool
true so I think when things start to get
a little weary they don't know you know
people know what's to what's going on
yeah what um what's your husband like
he's cool he's uh his name is Raphael
and my son's name is leafar which is
Raphael spelled backwards lefar yeah
it's pretty cool wow I know I wish I had
a cool name that sounded good backwards
yeah I don't yeah but it's cool he you
don't I just read it I know sorry
sorry yeah davat
but yeah it's very you should get your
son a vulture or something for Christmas
I feel
like I bet anyway sorry sorry sorry for
making so many jokes about your
aesthetic and stuff but it's cool I
never some are very accurate though well
I wish I gotten to talk to more people
that light are goth people I think I
think I don't ever do I don't know if I
don't go to enough goth places I think
I've always kind of had a affinity for
goth women maybe I think oh my brother
likes goth women too I think or he likes
Creative Ladies kind of like artsy yeah
and yeah I think where I was growing up
being artsy was weird you know I think
it was like people thought you was gay
or something you know or you was damn
gay or whatever if you you know did like
I remember if you got good grades you
know people thought you were homosexual
you know really oh yeah dude and so it
was like yeah so I think being brave
enough probably where and when I was
little to have uh somebody be like
unique yeah like you seem uh like you
are I think it that would have been so
maybe that's why I think it's really
fascinating I may I think it's maybe the
trauma like that's like like because I
think about why does it why do I think
cigarettes are sexy right like because
there's this like sense of
like you don't care that you're damaging
yourself and there's like a not a danger
to it but just like
it's self-destructive a little bit and I
think with maybe it's
just
like there I don't know like some some
of my favorite bands and the music I
listen to It's like there's some stuff
that I'm like oh they're they're good
but you could tell they just like they
don't have any trauma like so it's like
I just don't listen to happy I don't
like happy I don't I'm not attracted to
it you know what I mean yeah um so yeah
maybe that's what it's what it takes I
know I've had trauma I mean I've seen
some crazy things do a lot of people
mistake you and Dave Navaro ever or not
no but you know what I do hate is like
um because I really want to have bangs
and every time I've ever cut bangs
people call say that I look like share
and I don't think I look anything like
share I think it's because we have a
deep voice right oh yeah that could be
it I saw Sher at a game she was running
around with a young brother at a out of
out at the Super Bowl last year yeah
yeah she's dating like a 17-year-old I
think or 18 sorry yeah but um yeah um
yeah but I don't look like Dave Navaro
take that back sorry you don't look DAV
I was just trying to think if like
somebody were like really ridiculous
that they would run up and say that dude
the saddest thing his the his mother got
murdered I know I did a portrait of her
on him you did yeah no way mhm
wow uh the street I lived on is where it
happened in Los Angeles oh really yeah
and it always I always think about him
him all the time for some reason I guess
because of that or something is the
interesting guy never got to meet him uh
I'm I don't I really know him that well
yeah yeah yeah I never got to know him
or or know anything about him but yeah I
just remember that I like Jane's
Addiction oh dude yeah bro a friend of
mine threw his one-year-old birthday as
kid his kid's birthday at Perry
Ferrell's house right so I knew about
per I I didn't know I knew about James
addiction but I didn't know Perry frell
right so I'm over there just kind of
lurking lawyering wait somebody's kids
birthday yeah my friend uh they didn't
have a lot of like they like you know in
La a lot of times if somebody finally
gets a nice house everybody starts
throwing their children's parties there
because it's a big enough space yeah
okay so yeah they did it there and Perry
frell was in there and I didn't know I
was just kind of loitering around in the
other room cuz I'm hanging out with a
bunch of [__] one-year-olds you know
what I'm saying dude well I was just
thinking about this the other day
because it was my kid's birthday right
and he's like super into Billy Idol
right now like he loves Billy Idol and
he not not even Billy Idol he loves
Steve Stevens which is the the guitarist
of Billy Idol and I just love that my
kid thinks he's so cool you know and he
has this little like plastic red guitar
that like he'll be in front of the
mirror at the house and he'll make the
faces like like Steve Stevens and so I
tattooed Steve a while back I did a
portrait of his beautiful wife on him
and I was like I texted him I'm like and
I sent him a video of my son like oh and
and in the video I'm like hey who are
you and he's like I'm Steve Stevens and
like you know the coolest and so there's
a picture of him there yeah right
exactly I'm like oh I love it see my son
gets it you know and so I was like
should I because my friends were like
are you going to ask him to come because
I did a rock and roll themed birthday
party for him like you're going to ask
Steve Stevens to come and I was like no
dude I'm not going to do that because I
feel
like that's one thing that irks me about
like La people that they'll do that when
they get weird about their kids and
they'll be like I want to get like
without naming names I've like dated
some people that put their kids on these
weird pedestals and they'll like use
their name to get people to you know so
it's like I was like no I'm not going to
and also like it'll be weird if he just
like shows up and is just hanging out
with like a bunch of and a 5-year-old if
he's hanging out with a 5-year-old yeah
or just it'll be boring for him right
yeah it's like they it's like him and
him and Steve St can take a walk and
talk about their careers or whatever
together it's like yeah that part I
think would be kind of the strange part
I think it' be really probably sweet for
your son even though I did ask I did ask
leafar I'm like hey what would you do if
Steve if if you hung out with Steve like
I would take him to the pirate Park cuz
there's like a pirate ship park there
I'm like oh
cool you're Sonic the Hedgehog
toy did you um but one time one time a
long time ago Kirsty Ali hit me up
really and was like hey my son true is
like your biggest fan and he's having
and this is when he was really little
like he's like an adult now but um we're
having a Kat Von D themed birthday party
and they she showed me the cake and
she's like do she's like I know it's
weird and annoying but do you think you
could come over and just like surprise
him and I was just
like Chris is so cool you know like I
loved her you know and I was like should
I go over there and I was I was
tattooing that day and afterwards I just
rolled up and it was just so awkward
because it was just like hi and then
you're just like I don't have any tricks
like you know there's nothing to do so
yeah oh there's nothing weirder than
when you realize you don't have a skill
like an actual like skill like big
balloons or something unless you start
tattooing little kids you know um dude I
my best friend Scott his a his aunt
worked with Kirsty Ali and we went out
to Maine one time which is that's where
they live at like out on alboro island
so we got to go out there and we got to
go eat dinner at our house one day oh
cool it was pretty cool I think cool
like memor is not that great but I think
it was pretty great yeah and she had a
tennis court that was like kind of in
the ocean on these rocks really it was
literally in the ocean so it's just like
so cool and being on like Maine is so
like you know it's like so just like
yeah we'll see about that you know it's
got that [__] git in it yeah um Steen
King grit yeah a lot of [__] domestic
abuse up there as well I'm not pointing
fingers but you could Point them
anywhere up there and you'd be right uh
but yeah I love that place Portland Main
have you been there Portland no one of
my most favorite cities oh really yeah I
didn't know it would be amazing and it
would actually blew my mind okay um is
there a place that you really like uh
I'm not going to say it because it's
Uber goth oh it is Transylvania no I
would say um like Prague was my favorite
place oh yeah yeah just the Gothic
architecture and stuff and also I love
Beethoven and like I there I'm be a nerd
right now but one of his Apartments is
there and so I went and like took a
picture in front of the apartment and
everything oh that's cool yeah yeah I'm
trying to think if I've seen anybody's
good death place or or place that's
like have you ever done any weird like
rituals or something I'm sure people
think that you've done some no no but um
my friend and I we used to collect
pictures at cemeteries all around the
world which I thought was really cool
yeah like the I think my two favorite
cemeteries that I've ever been to well
there's three but um there um obviously
in Paris there's the the famous one with
where Edith PE off and Oscar wild and
everyone else is buried there um and
then there's one in Argentina that is
like the coolest one ever and there's
like this huge weight list to get buried
there but um it's just the most
Monumental mosks or whatever they're
called but super cool you just walk and
see all the architecture um yeah and New
Orleans is like that too I went to the
to to the New Orleans was was good but
um it was right after the Hurricane
Katrina a lot of the like body parts and
things back up yeah yeah a lot of people
coming back to like probably get money
from the government or whatever like
even bodies where like you know you see
an arm coming out of the ground like
give me a check you know it's just that
kind of City I think over there
yeah um what else do you want to do
you've had an interesting life cat yeah
um and look I know some of the things we
say like being able to leave Los Angeles
and do that kind of things we've at
least had enough been able to like I
don't know I sometimes wonder does that
seem like egotistical you know I mean I
never want to put down like LA because I
I love La you know like I love the dirt
there I love my friends I love a lot of
aspects of it um yeah and the weather
being able to go to the beach if you
want the beach oh yeah that's true huh
that's your arch nemesis yeah the sun I
forgot about that
sorry you got to put me back in that
little box with a bow on it yeah I know
what if your name had been cat vitamin D
that would have been so ironic well you
know I thought like what if you and I
would have gotten married then my name
would have been cat Von Von yeah
yep people like damn this lady's uh
interested looking but even crazier
she's got
dyslexia oh who that stutter stutter
yeah the stuttering Icelandic chick yeah
she's
something oh that's cute yeah um oh
there's some pictures from uh that we
had of some uh tattoos that we wanted to
just look at with you is that okay for a
minute okay I'm sure people have done
this a lot do I have to say bad things
about him no no what want oh but I want
to ask about your tattoos so you are
getting uh you're getting Inked out what
is it is there a term for it's really
fascinating looking it reminds me one of
those hairless cats kind of yeah I have
hairless cats um yeah I just I've been
blacking out all my tattoos and so I'm
in the process I have like almost 80% of
my body done now oh my God yeah but I'm
not it's not going to look like a like
I'm wearing a scuba diving like bang
it's G to I'm going to have like these
like black flowers kind of you know so
how and how long does this process take
kind of do I I think I'm I'm up to 40 40
hours now so but but I mean I've done
like the arms yeah but in increments I
you know I go and I can't sit for more
than two or three hours and there's this
guy in in Philly that um he like
specializes in it but it's funny because
you know when I first got into tattooing
was during a time when there was no
tattoo shows or anything so it was like
you would not get hired if you had a
face tattoo or you know what I mean it
was different era and then I think when
like certain celebrities started getting
tattooed like the drewberry Moors and
the Angelina Julies like it started kind
of bringing it to the like if you had a
tattoo a cute one it was okay you know
and then the TV shows like blew up and
then everybody has a tattoo now and it's
kind of boring but um but I feel like
ever since I started blacking out my
tattoos I feel like I went back to the
time where people hated tattoos again
cuz people just do not like this they
like they're very confused by why I'm
doing this every time I post progress
shots it's always like why are you doing
this to yourself like this is so ugly
like this is you know I think it looks
for some reason I I didn't know what I
think it looks nice I I did too I like I
like the interesting yeah it's almost
fascinating in a strange way like it's
like the inverse of something yeah
exactly you know it's like that car it's
like car I don't know what it is um but
it's yeah it's so I'm not I don't like
pain so I you know I just numb myself up
and you know he sits there and Tattoos
me when you say numb yourself what do
you put on an analgesic or something you
do anesthetics like like like a cream
does that work really yeah I mean it
saves me like a good an hour and a half
or something like that yeah no I can't
do pills I can't do anything like yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah I can't do nothing
like that boy nope I don't do no pills
Bubby yeah um um and so how much now
you're going to get 80% of your body
done no I'm going to do all of it your
whole body's going to be in a in a uh in
dark ink uhhuh your whole body's going
to be in dark ink yeah and now but but
it'll have like sections that are like
you know like see how there okay so
parts that aren't yeah yeah yeah oh
interesting wow it's almost like
uh it reminds me of like stained glass
or something for some reason um it it'll
look nice I like like people need to
trust the process it'll look good at the
end yeah if anybody has an eye for
something that's unique or trying to do
something new I like that yeah it seems
like you would be at least granted
that ability to experiment yeah oh yeah
here's a video of you right here yeah so
that's like my last session I
did wow I after what is that boy is that
a damn cake cutter that's 40 needles God
damn brother that
thing
wow yeah that's cool where do your do
your folks have your folks been to visit
your new place my dad has yeah my dad's
my contractor so oh he is huh oh good
you can [__] at him easier and what
about your mom um she lives in Southern
California oh yeah yeah are you guys
close or not not as close yeah but I
think you know once I when I had my son
I feel like she likes being a grandma
and oh she does yeah yeah I think so oh
that's cool yeah yeah that's one thing
that's fascinating about kids it like
gives your family a chance to like
regroup a little I think you know I
remember when my niece was born it just
like was the first time that our family
started to have any semblance of a
family it felt cuz we all had one thing
in common that we cared about yeah and
it was undisputable and so it was like
it starts to like other things start to
kind of Bloom from that a little bit
that's cool um yeah that must be
traumatic hearing people's stories when
they come to tattoo cuz some people are
coming with a story huh yeah every
single one I don't think I've ever
tattooed somebody that just you know was
getting tattooed out of boredom or
anything like that yeah yeah a lot of
our therapists in the world are getting
uh they're oversaturated with pain I
think from other people yeah yeah what
do you mean I just think there's a lot
of therapists a lot of my friends that
are therapists they are oversaturated
with people's you know because even if
somebody shares their story of uncomfort
or pain it still lands on somebody yeah
you know and I find a lot of my friends
that are therapists are starting to
struggle because they are like water
logged yeah with other people's like
trauma and sharing of it and stuff yeah
it's got to be a heavy job well that's
what I thought when you said about
tattoo workers I never thought or artist
tattoo artist I'd never thought about
that yeah I mean I I I love hearing
people's story so I'm always very
welcoming to or I was welcoming to all
that stuff so you know it never bothered
me but I know that a lot of tattooers
didn't want to didn't want to hear it
yeah what would they do what do you say
quiet tattoo time only no I just think
that like I think when the TV shows came
out people saw as an outlet for therapy
which it can be you know but some people
aren't equipped emotionally to do that
you know for me I'm like I I I can talk
about anything I don't care yeah you
know and I ended up studying books on
death and everything just so I could
better understand grieving processes and
stuff I'm not a therapist by any means
but you know well these days anybody who
will listen to somebody caringly I think
is is better than H sometimes is better
even than half the stuff we have out
there yeah um there's a lot of [__]
therapists out there too you know
because anybody can do it yeah you just
have to go to school and then they'll
let you do it yeah that's [__] crazy
dude yeah I wonder how much that works
yeah yeah but I mean there's a lot of
great therapists but you have a lot of
therapist friends yeah a lot of friends
that are therapists and you just start
to see that they're getting I start to
notice a lot of them having a tough time
and it's like I think a lot of that is
just them taking on that people's pain
you know and I'd never thought that
tattoo artist here a lot of it I just
never even thought about it yeah I mean
at different types I'm sure like if
you're doing you know dragons all day
I'm sure it's not a the same experience
but what's what's the toughest part for
somebody to get a tattoo on them what do
you mean toughest like like the hardest
part yeah um I
think like some people assume that like
if if you have like a fatty area it's
not going to hurt as much but it's more
based on your nerve setup so you know
your your spine you're going to have a
lot of nerves branching off of it so
places like your lower back or your butt
like things like that are pretty
sensitive but I don't know like your
butt cheek is is sensitive I remember
like the crease where my leg meets my
butt is was fire that seems scary the
back of your kneecaps
like do you think there's something
about the pain of getting the tattoo
that is also part of the I don't know I
don't I never I'm not one of those
people I know there's like kinky people
I don't I never like I was that's not
their thing I don't know I I I have a
hard time with it I don't like
it um anything else we can think about
or talk about do you ever find that
video on mcau
culen I just thought that this was in
I'd like to thank
Brenda you are absolutely
everything
um uh you're my Champion
you're you're the only person happier
for me today than I
am um you're not only the best woman
I've ever known you're the best person
I've ever known uh you've given me just
all my purpose you give me
family um you know and after the birth
of our two boys you become one of my
three favorite
people you're somewhere in
there but um I love you I love you so
much um so yeah to to wrap things up uh
and in the spirit of the holiday season
I just want to say uh Merry Christmas
you filthy
animals what his life was like there's a
part in the beginning of that where he
seems kind you're you're kind of like he
still seems like a kid and a
man I never heard his speaking voice
like as an adult until now yeah is there
anything else that you'd like to talk
about CAD is there any other like
endeavor you think about in your world
do you think you'll go back to tattooing
or do you still do it
um is that a weird question I don't I
don't know a ton about tattooing no no
it's cool um yeah I think I'll I'll
always want to tattoo until my eyesight
goes or something but I don't know if
I'm interested in doing um like I I just
you know I I stopped doing tattoos for
money decades ago it's been like you
know almost like 15 years or something
like I just I just tattoo my friends you
know oh yeah yeah cuz I think uh the
dynamic is can be pretty intense
sometimes if you're tattooing like
people you don't know you know so cuz
you're like in a room together
intimately for like you know hours
you're stuck in there some know it been
a nightmare being stuck in a room with
somebody uh I'm never alone but like or
usually when I used to tattoo strangers
but uh but now you know um I just tattoo
my friends stuff do people like say they
hire you for like specific a guest T
like is that kind of thing happen as a
tattoo artist like when you get to have
a claim as a tattoo artist do they say
like I want you to come and do my tattoo
like I want to hire you like oh like how
do how do you book an appointment you
mean or or like specifically like does
that happen like some people might like
uh commiss no what's it called
commission commission yeah yeah yeah I
mean I would always yeah yeah I mean it
kind of works that way like people when
I used to take appointments it would be
more like they'd have to show me what
they wanted to get and have like you
know a little bit of the backstory that
kind of thing and then we would have
like a booking process but now do people
does it ever you get a ring from like a
prince of like Nottingham or something
and they want to does that happen to
yeah and I don't like that I don't like
when people like like want me to go to
them because like first of all it's like
you're creating a sterile environment
and so like I don't want to do that in
your kitchen you know I've only done
that like a few times for for my friends
friends but like right I something about
like I don't know I don't like feeling
like a like a stripper or something oh
so the okay there's something about that
then oh yeah that's interesting yeah oh
I would hate to be a
stripper I would be so bad at it I don't
like people seeing my I think like my
butt sometimes I think like sometimes if
I hook up with a woman or something I'll
walk out of the room backwards they
don't look really yeah I don't think
there's anything wrong what's weird with
it nothing is wrong with it I think I
just like I think just know that when
you stand up after we're done here I
think people just makes me nervous I
think because I know I look at people's
butt sometimes so I'm just like dude so
I just got to stop looking at people I'm
self-conscious about that stuff too to
be honest like I feel like I even in in
photo shoots I always try and conceal
myself somehow yeah I was like hide
behind things
but yeah I love to be dude I'd play hide
and go seek dude i' go hide I'd [__]
leave I'd go home dude my buddy's out
there looking for me for 3 hours Bro
[__] him son that's life you better get
used to it
buddy um yep thank you so much cap on D
and everybody you just you know you can
just find her wherever you usually find
people and um best of luck with your new
home I want to see when that tulip
Garden's going to be done I know yeah
you have to come up yeah what's the ETA
on that thing you think I think in
Spring is usually when they come up yeah
boy yeah that Canna be interesting oh
you got to get a good Scarecrow in
it yeah maybe not yeah you could I yeah
it you don't want to it's fine yeah yeah
that's all good uh cat thank you so much
yeah no worries thanks for having me y
now justo on the breeze and I feel I'm
falling like these leaves I must be
Cornerstone oh but when I reach that
ground I'll share this piece of mind I
found I can feel it in my
bones but it's going to
take
little